let's get some analysis from charles
payne of fox business charles great to
see you uh you listened to the president
today your thoughts
yeah i watched the whole thing i was
somewhat frustrated brett because this
is a serious issue and you know you can
tell americans don't believe your eyes
or your pocketbooks
and and i i don't think these kind of
events help i watched the entire thing
it was mostly hey we a bragging session
about uh you know it being these things
not happening before christmas uh you
know this supply chain issue is going to
go on for a long time now there are
short-term reasons for it but there are
also long-term reasons for it and i
think the most important thing to
understand is that the the average
american is suffering mightily it's not
about the christmas presents people may
not have gotten i'm waiting on a few uh
things including some air hockey tables
i don't think will make it but
but the point is uh you know these
sessions should be designed as
to seek solutions you know and every
time they turn into some sort of
cheerleading hey look what we did kind
of thing and it doesn't help it doesn't
solve the problems and it certainly
doesn't help with i think the public
image we do have some serious problems
with supply chains and some of them are
going to go away naturally listen the
last fiscal stimulus checks have gone
out
that of course is one of the things that
created demand uh when all that demand
came up everyone went to the computers
they hit a few buttons bought a lot of
stuff and put them on ships from china
the problem is with those containers and
our lopsided
uh
economic relationship with china
when ships leave here they don't have
that many containers on them because
china is not buying our products so they
charge so much more
over the last several months has been
two three four times as much to ship
something from there to here well guess
who pays the price we do so there's some
things in there you know some of the
ceos were pretty cool uh fred smith who
i love you know if you ever get a chance
to look at his college thesis on fedex
that he got a c on right
but you know again i was hoping for more
of a solutions oriented conversation
yeah so if you're telling somebody at a
holiday party or just somebody that
you're meeting with what's the state of
the economy as we're heading into 2022
what do you charles payne say
i think i think the economy is is good
um
but i am worried about some of the uh
some of the signs ahead some of the
interesting things ahead listen we came
into 2021 we came into this year in
amazing shape household balance sheets
were stronger than they ever been
we sent out trillions of dollars people
paid off debt they bought stuff and they
put some in the bank so household
balance sheets the ability to spend
money after you've paid your bills
never never been better same thing with
corporate balance sheets and we had a
vaccine uh you know i think we're going
to be slower next year
i'm concerned i'm to be quite frank with
you i'm happy that this buildback better
has paused and maybe won't go through i
think it would have been more of a
problem in terms of disinflation crisis
which is the number one crisis in this
country so yeah you know what the
economy will slow hopefully inflation
will slow as much hopefully we won't
have any mistakes at the federal reserve
and i like that president biden brought
up small businesses or business
applications that's the ethos of america
right pulling yourself up by the
bootstraps it began last year it's
continuing this year it makes me very
hopeful particularly young millennials
and gen zers they're going out their
bread and they're making it happen
well let's hope for a good 2022 charles
payne merry christmas happy new year
you too my friend hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else